let's continue looking at the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with the Incredible
Hulk now it's impossible to talk about
this movie without talking about the
film version that came before the Hulk
many people regard it not as one of the
worst comic-book movies ever made but
one of the biggest comic-book mistakes
ever made the movie was directed by
Angley who just got done doing Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon this is a very good
talented director but he was obviously
the wrong one for this the movie was too
abstract too dramatic who slow paced and
somehow made the story of a giant green
man who smashes things boring so it was
pretty tough to do a reboot several
years later with that bad taste ill in
our mouths isn't much better than the
last one well yeah but it's still not
that uh okay let's look at the story the
film brilliantly starts off with an
opening credits sequence that actually
kind of shows what happened in the
previous film Bruce Banner is a
scientist who discovers this formula
that makes him a green monster in
dangers his girlfriend who's the
daughter of a general gets chased by the
military and disappears into the Amazon
that is the exact plot of the previous
film and yet it's not exactly a sequel
if you came into this film not seeing
the first one you could just see it as
oh this is the backstory of this
character but there's just enough little
changes that you could see it as a
reboot it's very very clever that way in
my opinion is probably the smartest
thing in the movie Bruce Banner this
time is played by Edward Norton which
seems like a good choice he spends his
time now in the jungle trying to find a
cure for his condition but the army as
well as his girlfriend
played this time by Liv Tyler are still
on the lookout for one man volunteers as
guinea pig played by Tim Roth who also
chases banner while starting to get
injections turning himself into a giant
green monster
thus the movie ends with Hulk vs. Hulk
with one giant green monster pounding
another giant green monster in a city on
paper it sounds like this would be done
a lot better and even in the film it
kind of is Edward Norton is a very good
replacement and he does a great job in
the role I'm always impressed how a guy
with such a baby face and a high-pitched
voice can come off as such an
intelligent badass everything he says
just sounds
you know he's not bullshitting around
ever Tim Blake Nelson plays a good
scientist who may or may not be evil and
Tim Roth once again is a very enjoyable
villain the surprising downside of this
movie is that once again the wow factor
is very minimal
at first the build-up is great you see
the Hulk in the shadows it's kind of
hard to make him out he makes this
appearance in a factory behind the smoke
and it's really good but then the more
you see of them the less impressive he
seems to be I mean yeah he growls and
snorts and jumps around and throws
things but when you think of a Hulk
movie you want to see the Hulk do really
cool stuff even the first film at least
had some scenes rais'd throwing a tank
and jumping on planes here he's just
kind of running around and I know the
argument she won the focus be on Bruce
Banner and his emotional struggle and
all that stuff sure but it's still
called The Incredible Hulk and we want
to see the Hulk do something incredible
and you just don't see much of that in
this film even the complicated plan from
the villain kind of seems out of nowhere
and I know you can make the argument
yeah the serums and everything they're
making him crazy but haven't we seen
that a lot of times before hasn't it
been done a lot better when you see
their dissent with this guy it just
seems like oh I want to stop him because
it's my mission and now I'm just kind of
nuts I don't know Javert he ain't help
even Javert is a Javert but that's in
our story it also feels like they're
setting up some things that now in
hindsight don't really go anywhere like
there's a scene where Tim Blake Nelson
gets knocked out and you see him almost
kind of go through a weird
transformation you think oh what's this
gonna be is is gonna be a new villainous
is gonna be a new bad guy but no he
never appears in a of the other movies
at least not that I know of
on the whole guess I wasn't really upset
that I saw it or anything I didn't feel
like a time was wasted it just didn't
feel like it was anything that
spectacular or even really that
interesting it was the perfect
definition of okay you want Z I would
Norton be okay you want to see Tim Roth
be okay you want to see the effects be
okay that's what you're gonna get an
okay movie but again it's the Incredible
Hulk why are we only getting okay with
the Incredible Hulk I don't know I know
this movie kind of got panned when I
came out and I don't think it's quite
that bad like I said I don't even really
think it's really terrible by any means
it's just kind of underwhelming once
again though I have to talk about the
after credit sequence in this one you
think the movie is over and they're just
gonna have a little throwaway joke at
the end but out of nowhere suddenly
there's Robert Downey jr. as Tony Stark
this is very common nowadays for Marvel
movies but back then you never saw this
you never saw an a-list actor from a
Marvel movie suddenly come in saying hey
matter that thing we teased at the end
of our other film we're really fuckin
doing it and this is when Robert Downey
jr. suddenly exploded as this big
celebrity so to suddenly see him pop in
at the end
not just for a little laugh but actually
saying yeah we're holding true to our
promises
it was actually kind of chilling people
suddenly start to say holy smokes are
they really doing this our Iron Man and
a Hulk gonna be in a movie and if so
does that mean we're gonna get Thor
Captain America and God knows how many
other Avengers are out there the idea
was suddenly seeming possible so I guess
in a very strange way the most
incredible part of the Incredible Hulk
was the credits and I guess you could
take that as an insult but they were
done really well but what I say about
the rest of the movie like I said it's
passable not good not bad just passable
if you're in the mood to see a Hulk film
that's better than the first one but
still doesn't quite reach that level of
incredible miss give it a rent it's
worth a few hours of your time